So, gef rehab
das ist hart oder was ich soll dir das bild schicken ok ah gut computer spiele preis vielleicht
kriegen wir vielleicht kriegen wir das bild noch besser hin
oh greb vielleicht kriegen wir das bild im fullscreen noch besser hin ohne ohne einblendung
irgendwie ok jetzt blendet sich nicht mehr aus das ist aber der beste moment gewesen
dass der strieb stehen bleibt speichern noch mal eins ich hoffe der strieb geht jetzt wieder
mein dsl modem nicht mal dsl mein kabel modem hat desynced einfach so oh nee schon wieder kaputt
oder schon wieder kaputt aber aber der strieb ist repp
zwischen auf steam das ist schon alle ehrenwert und ich würde sagen wir gucken uns mal an was die
jungs zu sagen haben ganz ehrlich soll ich euch mal meine ehrliche meinung sagen mich
juckt der deutsch computer spielepreis überhaupt nicht ich glaube wir hören jetzt auf zu gucken
oder wollt ihr weiter gucken mich juckt überhaupt gar nicht es ist mir absolut scheiß egal
ne bitte nicht schauen was genau macht es schoneberger bei der computer spielpreis
man weiß es nicht so genau die war letztes jahr auch da das ist wahrscheinlich auch das
was sie qualifiziert wahrscheinlich dass sie auch vorhanden ist ja es gibt ja bestimmt
genug die das moderieren können warum ist denn jetzt eigentlich alles hier mega im arsch
warum warum geht mein pp gabot nicht weil eben mein internet kaputt war mcfly hat abonniert
keine sounds gekommen btf leute ich höre keine ich höre keine subsounds dankeschön für den
sup okay wir machen es wieder aus gefahr ist die schalte okay wir machen das trick 17 machen
es einfach in prom auf exe geht auch nicht wo ist das problem das ist lokales fuck okay
ribut ribut easy neuer p das ist lokal bei mir das ist lokal bei mir da gibt es nix mit
ributen also da wo wir gerade beim thema sind ihr habt gesagt ich soll mir das video hier
angucken mal gucken wir uns jetzt mal das video an und flamen ein bisschen mit ich habe ja
auch schon ein paar videos zu dem thema gemacht und mein fazit war ja auch immer eher eher
schlecht aber ich muss erst wieder mein pp gabot zum laufen bekommen sonst kann es sein dass
ich nicht connecten kann zu zu fonts google api was auch immer kann es sein dass ich nirgends
wohin connecten kann gerade es ist grad daun oder phone.de watte her warum ist das warum
ist das warum kann ich mich bei einer vm nirgends wohin connecten oh geht ja auch nicht oh leute
der dns ich habe google dns drinne ich habe ich habe den google dns drinne oder?
habe ich den google dns drinne ha ich komme nicht mehr zum google dns aber wisst ihr was
das gute ist leute ähm der stream läuft aus irgendwelchen unerfindlichen gründen noch
oh 1111 geht easy wir stellen um eigentlich will ich jetzt nix anfassen eigentlich will
ich jetzt nix anfassen ich hoffe es geht einfach alles ich hoffe es geht einfach alles
wir können halt keine videos aufmachen und so aber das geht ja bestimmt gleich wir gucken
jetzt einfach das video hier an das geht auch das läuft auch weiter alles gut alles top
wunderbar oh nee f verarscht mich net hier ist nix f der chat alter der chat wisst ihr
was wir machen wenn ihr mich weiter gebadet leute hier wird nicht gebadet hier wird nicht
gebadet leute so gucken wir uns das video an was gucken wir uns mal das video an ja passt
ja gerade passt exzellent passt ja gerade ähm zum thema wir gucken wir beobachten mal ob
der google dns wieder zu funktionieren glaubt ähm ist eigentlich meine mikrofon settings
richtig das ist gerade richtig das ist wirklich so so voll in der schwebe ich ich gucke jetzt
alle zwei sekunden rüber ob das stream noch läuft weil die unity media so am abscheißen
ist wor davon ich habe halt die bedenken wenn ich da jetzt den neuen dns ich meine das ist
windows ja ich meine das ist das ist windows und ähm ich habe angst dass er das netzwerk
interface reconnectet wenn ich den dns ändere leute windows profis reconnectet der das netzwerk
interface neu wenn ich den dns ändere ich weiß noch nicht mal wie man überhaupt in
das komische menü reinkommt einfach machen bäm äh was ist überhaupt das richtige interface
hier der da glaube ich blöbelm also probieren wir mal ja gut das ist mein eigener dns der
geht aber direkt auf google 11111 bäm bäm so und google geht wieder was kirby gommi race
ist nicht am start wat nintendo out anzeige ist raus ip league auf fack leute jetzt ist
vorbei moment wo war es wo war es ip league scheiße rip ip league omfg das ist raus ok
gucken wir uns mal das video an weil es passt ja richtig gut zum thema ja wir auch gerade
schon wieder neues update für call of duty und 20 gigabyte aber wollte ich eigentlich
nur mal eine gemütliche runde zucken bis das update geladen ist da ist es morgen früh
was soll der scheiß ja das frage ich mich auch warum die updates haben die größer sind
als die meisten spiele
doch ich glaube von ihm habe ich schon mal was gesehen
ja es hat jemand gemeint er schreit nicht aber man kann sich auch aufregen ohne zu
schreien existiert nein es existiert schon seit jahrzehnten nämlich das thema internet
in deutschland und wie ihr an meiner haue blassen falen und der schrumpeligen haut sehen
können bin ich ja jetzt nicht unbedingt mehr ein teeny und habe die internetzeit von anfang
an bis heute miterlebt
ja leute wer hatte wer hatte noch einen modem bei sich daheim aber noch genug boomer im chat
die das miterlebt haben also ich hatte sowohl in 336 als auch in 56k
ich sehe es ich sehe es leute 56k boomer ja ich hatte sogar ein modem hat schon mal erzählt
mit fachs mit eingebautem vier megabyte flash speicher wo man fachse drauf speichern konnte
auf dem modem und sogar anrufe mit vier megabyte flash
stell euch das mal vor mit vier megabyte flash das ist heute mehr als auf meinem microcontroller
drauf ist weniger als auf meinem microcontroller drauf ist
ich gehöre zu denjenigen die noch mit einem herkömmlichen quäkenden modem das internet
erkundet haben ich gehöre noch zu der aol-ära mit diesem wunderbaren satz hier sie haben
post ich war damals happy als wir istn bekommen haben und ich mit leitungsverdoppelungen istn
war auch so ein ding wo sie meiner ansicht nach komplett die zeit verschlafen haben istn
war so dass war istn war komplett telefon optimiert da war internet ein zweiter gedanke
dabei istn war telefon fachs und und und und halt so so oldschool telekommunikationsservice
optimiert ans internet hat da überhaupt keiner gedacht
war n witzige 14 kilobyte die sekunde daunen konnte zu hohen kosten wohlgemerkt bei aol
kommen erst mal so allgemein minutenabrechnungen zu ich weiß es nicht mehr ganz genau aber
ich meine es waren so fünf bis sieben d-mark pro stunde was damals sehr hohen achso ok das
war vielleicht dann noch vor meiner zeit weiß ich nicht aber so teuer war es nicht als ich
angefangen habe im 56 kam oder du musstest aber zweimal bezahlen du musstest da internet
provider bezahlen und du musstest die telefon kosten bezahlen und telefon gebühren ja genau
eine sehr teure angelegenheit und daher nur was für blasse und picklige computer freaks wie ich
einer war und damals waren gefühlt andere länder schon deutlich weiter als wir und irgendwann kam
der zeitpunkt an dem fast alle welt auf glas gesetzt hat ist es nicht schön ist es nicht
kanalbündelung kanalbündelung war tatsächlich nice wo man sonntags hinter wo man sonntags
kosten kostenlos in anführungsstrichen ins internet konnte da hat man kanalbündelung
angeschlossen und konnte damals dann mit was verheißt ihren kanalbündelung 12k 16k 16k
oder es war was war was weiß gar nicht mehr genau 14,5k 14,4k es war auf jeden fall nicht
schnell und es war aber richtig cool weil man damals napster benutzen konnte und man konnte
damals mit ist ihren kanalbündelung sachen auf napster downloaden und gleichzeitig abspielen also
so ein art streaming leider nein denn ein kleines aber sehr starkes industrie land mit einem leucht
über gewichtigen bundeskanzler schwamm gegen den strom und setzte voll und ganz auf kupfer ja das
ist natürlich auch so schön rot-golden ja unter dieser entscheidung hat deutschland bis heute zu
knabbern das stimmt nun kommen wir zu dem punkt auf dem ich das stimmt und lustigerweise in den
bereichen wo man glas verlegt haben wir so gemacht dass es jetzt nicht mehr verwenden bei es das
internet in deutschland ist absoluter müll ja sicher es gibt viele länder den es internetmäßig
noch deutlich schlechter geht ja ugan da verheimlichen turkmenistan ist zum beispiel so
weit unten im weltweiten downloadlisten dass das land einem wirklich leid tun kann mit nicht
mal zwei mw download im schritt aber deutschland ist die viertgrößte wirtschaftsnation der welt
noch und im weltweiten vergleich der download geschwindigkeiten befinden wir uns hinter ländern
wie z.b. slovenien der slowakei wie leton unga oder wie estland kein hate alles durchaus schöne
länder aber so richtige industrienationen sind das jetzt nicht unbedingt was ist los mit dem
deutschen internet und laut der aktuellsten statistik von cable.co.uk wo deutschland 2019
quasi kein wachstum bei der internetgeschwindigkeit ja weil wir sie auch seit jahren verkraten
weil wir auch so eine komische ausbau förderungsregeln wieder haben so nach dem motto hier wenn hier mal
modernisiert wurde das pepega board ist auch gegangen oft gegangen wenn das mal modernisiert
wurde dann darf jetzt die nächsten zehn jahren wieder nichts gemacht werden dann buddeln voter
phone telekom wäre auch immer alles parallel die straße auf es ist bei uns voll blanlos
noch schlechter als 2018 in der ganzen liste hinter uns finde ich nur zwei weitere westliche
industrienationen die vergleichbar sind und zwar österreich und großbritannien ok die briten
wollen eh nirgendwo zugehören und überall nur extrawürste die wollen ja eh mit niemand anderem
internetverkehr außer mit sich selbst durchaus möglich der ganze stream ist gerade dank voter
phone verreckt ja anscheinend haben wir gerade ein bisschen stream frame drops wieder ja aber
ich bin ja froh dass das stream überhaupt läuft wo das shit genau wo das shit daher britannien
egal aktuelle statistik von cable.co.uk besagt 2019 ein durchschnitts download von 25 mbit in
deutschland hier muss ich jetzt aber kurz noch erwähnen dass die daten von zum beispiel dieser
seite und zum beispiel von speedtest die ja auch reale daten nutzen keine vertraglichen die daten
enorm differieren das beste ist das beste ist immer noch der breit pand atlas und selbst wenn
der in den default settings geschönt ist und gehen wir mal von außen ist die geschönte variante
und die ist immer noch schlecht das sagt alles im schnitt zum beispiel 94,73 mbit und das ist
94,73 mbit ist aber sogar nur auf platz 31 zu finden meine erfahrungen sind den werten von
cable.co.uk aber eher zu trauen falls jemand eine idee hat wie diese enorm differenz zustande
kommt schreibt das bitte unbedingt in die kommentare denn ich habe überhaupt keine ahnung
und wer liegt an der spitze der liste nahezu unabhängig welche liste südkorea südkorea ist
glaube ich ziemlich gut oder die schweiz die schweiz ist doch auch gut ja da ist die schweiz
was hat südkorea nicht auch ordentlich internetanschluss scheint nicht so gut zu
sein hier dabei aber die schweiz ist ziemlich gut ich meine die müssen ja auch nur einen großen
funkmast auf den bash stellen und dann haben alle internet 71 mbit dahinter das absolute
traumzahlen für deutschland ja und in europa ist es wohl das sympathischste land des ganzen
kontinents die schweden haben in sachen internet ihre blonden haare weit vorne mit 55 mbit das
wäre für deutschland ja alles gar nicht so schlimm wenn es bei uns auch zumindest irgendwie
voran ginge aber genau das das kriegen wir nicht hin nicht die schweiz z.b. hat gegen
bei 2018 und 30 prozent zugelegt die schweiz ebenfalls so ein land das ja immer nur sagt
nein damit wollen wir nichts zu tun haben wir bleiben für uns alleine nein keine eu und
trotz diverser pakete der bundesregierung sehe ich ehrlich gesagt keine besserungen
in sicht trotz dass die bundesregierung viele milliarden an geldern bereitstellt geht es
einfach nicht voran denn diese gelder werden einfach nicht von den kommunen abgerufen
bürokratie wahnsinn ist nämlich das problem dann kommt natürlich auch noch die ganzen
anbieter dazu ob telekom obwohl davon ausbau findet nur in lukrativen gegenden statt und
so lange die regierung die anbieter da musste hat du musst die anbieter dazu zwingen im
endeffekt oder du gehst gleich so weit und sagst ja scheiß auf die anbieter wir kümmern
uns da von oberer stelle drum ob das jetzt besser wäre schwierig aber wie anbieter machen
das doch freiwillig warum sollte ein anbieter einen bauernhof anschließen der irgendwo
im arsch der welt liegt zum beispiel wozu was haben die davon nix kostet geld ohne ende
bringt nichts und was sie dazu bringt auch in nicht lukrativen gebieten auszubauen bleibt
es natürlich so wie es aktuell ist nur in extremen ballungsräumen gibt es glasfaser
woanders wird weiterhin auf veraltete kupferleitung und mit glück auch noch vdsl gesetzt statt
die glasfaser komplett bis ins haus zu legen tja und am geilsten sind ja so einige fälle
in den kommunen dass selbst in die hand genommen haben und glasfaser selbst gelegt haben nur
damit einige zeit später die telekom die cremen wieder aufbuddelt ja und dann ja das hast
du schon öfters mal gehabt richtig verstanden zweimal glasfaser das wäre ja nicht schlimm
das wäre überhaupt nicht schlimm wenn da zweimal glasfaser liegt sofern das halt kein
einfluss negativen einfluss hat nicht nur auf die telekom schieben das ist nun mal ein
wirtschaftsunternehmen das kostendeckend arbeiten muss das ganze ist nun mal ein regierungsproblem
und sorry wenn ich das jetzt mal direkt sage die meisten älteren damen und herren haben
aufsichtlich nun mal kein plan zum internet man hat ja bei denen immer das gefühl dass
nur das vorangebracht wird was auch persönlich interessiert und wichtig scheint dass es wird
überhaupt nichts vorangebracht was mich persönlich gar nichts vielleicht nicht aber sehr wenig
was mich persönlich interessiert sein aber es fühlt sich für mich auf jeden fall immer
so an und manchmal glaube ich sogar dass die alten damen und herren überhaupt nicht verstehen
wie wichtig schnelles internet für die wirtschaft in deutschland ist man kann sich doch nicht
ewig auf die auto metallbauindustrie verlassen wie er schon sei gefühlt hunderten von jahren
denn es ist so wir haben den digitalen anschluss komplett verpasst wo sind denn die großen
it konzern in deutschland wir haben wir haben witzigerweise ich habe letztes artikel drüber
gelesen tolles standbild ich habe letztens einen coolen artikel drüber gelesen dass
wir in deutschland gerade einen nennen wir es mal mini bis mittleren aufschwung beziehungsweise
neu gründung und erfolg von technik unternehmen haben und das fazit von diesem artikel hat
mich dann aber gleich wieder an die realität erinnert dass das ja dass das ja deutschland
ist und zwar haben die geschrieben dass es sich relativ viel neue technikunternehmen
gibt und auch relativ viel im vergleich zu früher erfolgreich sind und warum sind die
erfolgreich ja sap haben wir stopp haben wir nicht wir hatten mal crytech was games angeht
zumindest die sind zu dem fazit gekommen die ganzen etwas etwas kleineren und mittleren
it leden die jetzt gegründet werden die es schon eine weile gibt denen es jetzt gut geht
die halt gut was zu tun haben das liegt daran nicht weil die neue innovative sachen machen
sondern weil die ganz großen in deutschland gerade anfangen festzustellen dass sie it
mäßig und infrastruktur mäßig komplett hinten dran sind das heißt die kleinere
unternehmen sind nur erfolgreich weil sie den großen quasi sachen von vorgestern verkaufen
können weil die so weit hinten dran sind so ist das halt hier
großen online shops in deutschland wo die wirklich die großen online shops da muss
ich jetzt auch noch kurz mal die großen online also das haben wir auch so extrem krass verschissen
es leuchtet mir überhaupt nicht ein was in bochum gibt es auch start-up gründer szene
genau was ich sagen wollte das haben wir auch so verschissen und zwar wir hatten ja früher
was gab es da otto quelle neckermann und ich habe gelesen dass entweder was quelle oder
was otto zu dem zeitpunkt wo die noch wo die halt noch noch originalquelle otto waren dass
die bis zum schluss den meisten umsatz mit katalog deals gemacht haben was sie mir vorstellen
das ist ja noch gar nicht so lange her fünf jahr oder so was wir sich mal vorstellen so
und die haben es so die haben so heftig den anschluss verpasst die waren ja schon in deutschland
die waren schon lange da die waren etabliert und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass amazon
hier so easy fuß gefasst hätte und quasi immer leihgang die sache aufgerollt hätte
wenn die frühzeitig damit gemacht hätten und das ganze erkannt hätten aber das haben
die so verkackt das war sowas internet lull wir machen katalog ja fail ja das mag sein
dass das ich weiß nicht ob es otto oder oder quelle war als sie noch original waren das
kann durchaus sein dass das dass das jetzt anders ist wie sie zum beispiel in den usa
zu hauf gibt wobei natürlich auch die usa jetzt nicht das allerschnellste internet haben
so ehrlich muss ich mal sein ob clouds ob vpn ob home office datenverkehr zwischen firmen
schulen und ja auch uploads von youtubern und twittern die gehören zur industrie in
deutschland auch wenn das die regierung vielleicht ein bisschen anders sieht das alles funktioniert
in deutschland mehr schlecht als recht und ja den upload den vergessen viele übrigens
total denn der ist besonders für die industrie oft viel viel wichtiger als der download und
dass ein hoher download wenig bringt wenn der upload auf niedrigem niveau ist das muss
ich hoffentlich jetzt niemand erklären denn dazu bedarf es definitiv keines mathematik
professors in meiner alten firma musste ich zum beispiel sehr viel das internet nutzen
ich glaube das ist vielen gar nicht so klar also bei den normalen downloads ist es natürlich
wichtig dass man ein mindest eine mindestanzahl an upload hat sonst kriegt man gar nicht
den vollen download aber dafür ist potenziell genug da aber das verhältnis ist total beknackt
der cooper 1338 schreibt im chat kann was langes das muss ich gerade mal kurz vorlesen
weil was was gibt es da ein kumpel von mir hat ein praktikum bei bmw gemacht die wollen
sich dann für ein projekt eine digitale lösung einkaufen aha da kam dann unter anderem auch
sap ok zu einer präsentation die haben ungelogen richtigen müll gelabert gut das sind halt
vertriebs und bvl blender leute die mussten jetzt den ihren job quasi zu überzeugen und
also der schreibt und die haben ungelogen richtigen müll gelabert und die lösungen
ob es jetzt der chat weitergegangen und die lösung war super teuer und bot kaum vorteile
total statisch kaum raum für individualisierung und dann hatten die noch einen startup aus
frankreich die eine supergeniale innovative lösung präsentiert haben ja da wird sich
aber der chef denken das ding aus frankreich kann morgen weg sein keine saukenz gibt keine
zusätzlichen module wir kaufen sap und ihr habt garantiert sap gekauft zur zeit läuft
computerspiele preisfälle mitglied ja wir haben sogar am anfang mal reingeguckt ja guck
wir haben sogar ein schönes wir haben sogar ein schönes bild gemacht das sieht echt
zum fürchten oder wer wollte es mit dem emote machen ich schicke sie nachher im discord
am streben kaum möglich trotz offiziell 300 mitleitung für die ganze firma aber der kabel
vor kurzem habe ich mit meinem steuerberater gesprochen die hofft endlich auf glasfaser
freischaltung und meinte sogar dass das ganze geschäft schädigen wäre dass sie mit ihren
überhaupt kein ordentlichen datenaustausch durchschönen können weiteres beispiel bei
uns im ort das ist nicht nur geschäft schädigen das ist komplett geschäftshemmend wenn du
kein internetanschluss heutzutage hast langsam regerecht aus immer mehr firmen machen hier
dicht oder wandern ab die alten gebäude finden dann keine neuen besitzer warum das internet
natürlich ich würde mich dort nicht so im ort niederlassen der hier maximal 6 mbit im
download liefert und das ist natürlich nicht nur hier so welche möglichkeiten start ups
größere firmen und so weiter mit schnell im internet hätten das ist überhaupt nicht
auszumalen ja klar auch privates langsames internet mittlerweile natürlich ein graus
bestes beispiel natürlich aus meinem intro neue patch für ein spiel von mehreren gigabyte
damit ist der gemütliche zocker an bei mir in der regel immer geschichte oder youtube
mal ebenso schnell ein größeres video hochladen das ist überhaupt nicht möglich das dauerte
bei mir bis vor kurzem zwei bis drei stunden monti warum bist du nicht auf twitch erratet
mal weil mein upload scheiße ist könnte mich noch stundenlang über den ganzen mist aufregen
aber ich will natürlich auch irgendwann mal zum ende kommen wobei nein moment ein aufreger
den muss fremdrops es kann sein dass es fremdrops gibt wo davon beziehungsweise unity media
ist gerade wieder übelst am abscheißen geht geht eigentlich der google dns mittlerweile
wieder excellent ok geht geht wieder ist wieder ganz zu telekom natürlich ich musste mich
ja jahrelang mit einer offiziell 16 mbit leitung und ein mbit upload begnügen pc lustig schreibt
einmal ehrlich 80 prozent der meisten private benutzer brauchen doch kaum geschwindigkeit
doch brauchen sie also definiere mal was ist kaum in der heutigen zeit wo immer mehr
sachen in der heutigen zeit wo immer mehr sachen online gemacht werden die meisten
leute wenn die am rechner setzen am tablet am sonst wo das sind 90 prozent browser anwendung
die leute machen 90 prozent browser zeug die leute speichern immer mehr sachen online
die leute bearbeiten immer mehr sachen online es macht offline so richtig offline machen
die leute ja kaum noch was es werden daten gesungen es werden videos gestreamt es wird
musik gestreamt es sind mehrere leute im haushalt die heutzutage und das ist jetzt ja nicht
wirklich weit hergeholt dass jemand in 4k film guckt vielleicht noch jemand anderes
in 4k film guckt andere macht einen steam download und einer macht backup oder so das
ist ja nicht jetzt komplett utopisch was ich erzähle sind ganz normale anwendungsszenarien
die ganz normale 0815 familien mit vater mutter kind haben und da kommste mit 6 mp nicht
aus das reicht nicht das ist schlicht und ergreifend zu wenig da kommste nicht da kommste
nicht mit hin ich habe es ja mal in dem video gesagt dass wenn wenn wenn eine familie mutter
vater kind vielleicht sogar mutter vater zwei kinder gibt es aber die kriegen tatsächlich
zwei kinder noch ich kann zwar nicht verstehen ob kinder kriegt aber gut das ist ein anderes
thema aber vater mutter zwei kinder die brauchen eigentlich mindestens 50 mbit dass das wirklich
auch rund um die uhr halbwegs gut läuft auch in stoßzeiten und das gibt es halt wenig
wir haben uns noch letztens auf dem breitband ausbau das ganze angeguckt 50 mbit kriegste
bei weitem nicht immer zwölf mbit ankam immer wieder fragt ich die telekom wann ich den
mal immer mehr erhalte und seit jahren wurde mir immer wieder gesagt dass hier bei uns
ja ja das mit dem stream abkanten wurde davon hat richtige probleme gerade die da frame drops
unter ende wieder ach wurde davon meine fresse so ein scheißladen alle ich kündige jetzt
kündigung ist raus da gab es doch diese komischen störungen sind alle störungen genau bämm
leute guckt euch das mal an ja da gehts rauf flopp what the fuck okay ich stelle mal kurz
runter mal gucken ob das dann irgendwie was bringt
war was ist leak ist nichts leak leute jeges voll kaputt stb a 42 sechs monate stream settings
liegt auch ein gott
potato church man das liegt nicht unbedingt an den ganzen nupsemitter das liegt halt an
unseren provide und dies verkacken und generell am internet in deutschland wo wir gerade wieder
beim thema sind wir gucken das video ist noch mal kurz fertig der sub sound war kaputt habe
ich was übersehen ja das sub sound ist abgekackt mit wurde vorn stb a 42 huge sub dankeschön
sechs monate ansonsten noch ein vergessen oder stream lag wieder ich sehe sie davor
schon und ich kann nichts dagegen machen ich kann wirklich heute nix gar nix wir müssen
auch bei dem rumgespacke von wurde vorn nicht davon ausgehen dass es irgendwie heute anders
wird noch na
ich würde jetzt ja gern auf twitter gehen und wurde vorn flamen die sache ist plus die
leute im twitter support die haben damit die haben da überhaupt kein einfluss drauf und
letztendlich läuft es darauf raus dass man sich mit technikern beschäftigen muss die
auch nichts daran ändern können
guter raus und reingesteckt ist das all dies vom wlan geändert
so ich hoffe wir haben es jetzt erst mal zumindest das eine video jetzt fertig gucken können
er hat ja voll und ganz recht
sei so so ausbaugebiet dann kam immer in etwas rettung in form von meinem hybrid anschluss
mit 50 mb down und 10 mb upload und mir war hier hybrid anschluss das ist auch so das ist
auch so absolute bullshit technologie ich meine dass sie dass sie dass sie so gut an
fünf strechen funktioniert ist technisch nice gemacht ja aber dass man so eine scheiße
überhaupt braucht
deutlich wichtiger da meine videos so halt keine zwei bis drei stunden mehr zum upload
brauchten und ja der upload funktionierte durchaus stabil bei 10 bis 11 mbit stream
ist mit so einer hybrid leitung aufgrund der sehr wackeligen verbindung aber jetzt nicht
in guter qualität möglich das nun mal zur info ja beim download da sah es aber leider
sehr übel aus kaum mehr als mit normalem dls für kurze zeit vielleicht mal 30 mbit
meist aber leider deutlich unter 20 mbit ja und dann hat unser ort hier glasförster
einfach mal in die eigenen hände genommen und ausgebaut früher 2020 sollte es bei
mir dann auch so weit sein leider passte das ganz jetzt nicht mit dem kündigungstermin
der telekom zusammen der hat sich das jetzt so ein bisschen blöd überschnitten ja mein
telekom vertrag läuft jetzt leider noch ein ganzes jahr weiter nach der kündigung rief
dann eine dame an und fragte nach dem grund die nicht ihr natürlich nannte neue anbieter
mit glasfaser und eine katastrophal schlechte hybrid leitung und ich machte einen ganz
großen fehler ich sprach nämlich ein eventuelles sonderkündigungsrecht an weil bei mir halt
so wenig ankommt ob es das gibt weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht jedenfalls was passierte
nur wenige stunden später habe ich fast 60 download per hybrid gehabt ich kündige und
plötzlich geht es telekom wollt ihr mich eigentlich total verarschen ja und das ende
vom lied ich habe jetzt endlich mal einen lang ersehnten glasfaser anschluss muss aber
leider doppelt sein und das eine sache habe ich auch gemerkt dass du durchaus vorteile
hast wenn du wenn du nervig bist ja wie gesagt ich habe damals auch bei unity media einen
monat lang bin ich stehen auf twitter überall auf den sack gegangen und schon hatte ich
wieder hatte ich schon wieder kein dual stack light sondern einen ordentlichen anschluss
das ist zufällig mit dem speed ja es wäre merkwürdig würden sie das machen aber zumindest
bei vodafone beziehungsweise bei unity media hat das meckern was gebracht allerdings nicht
speed mäßig sondern halt dass ich kein dual stack light mehr hatte aber dafür bezahle
ich jetzt doppelt ist auch egal ich bezahle jetzt gerade doppelt power upload bei unity
media zweimal ich krieg ich krieg nur einmal power upload aber ich bezahle zweimal power
upload aber das ist es irgendwie auch wert dass ich dann endlich bald mal mit twitch
anfangen kann aktuell sind es dann 400 mb dauer und 100 mbit upload ob das jetzt so
ankommt weiß ich noch nicht da ich den anschluss bei produktion dieses videos hier leider
noch nicht im betrieb hatte und ja 400 mbit für glasfaser das ist wenig aber mehr ginge
auch aber ich denke mir wozu mehr ginge siehe vodafone noch so ein anbieter von dem man
überhaupt nichts gutes hört man hört von keinem anbieter gibt es irgendein anbieter
von dem man was gutes hört was jetzt nicht gerade in den lokalen lokale anbieter ist
über kabel soweit ich weiß bietet vodafone übrigens kein normales glasfaser an nun kabel
leitung haben wir halt leider so ihre tücken so natürlich auch bei vodafone die bieten
ein gigabit an im download hauptsache neue kunden akquirieren wie das technisch umsetzbar
ist das scheint vodafone doch völlig egal dass ich gehen die noch am arsch vorbei scheint
wohl jetzt schon ziemlich am limit zu sein ein gigabit kommt fast bei niemanden an viele
bekommen nicht mal die hälfte der zugesagten bandbreite und abends bricht das netz bis
zu bis zu super ein gigabit leitung vodafone klasse gemacht wer braucht sowas und was soll
der scheiß wenn du genug kapazitäten habt dann verkauft das sowas nicht ich finde sowas
sollte echt verboten werden und wo wir dann auch noch beim thema der vertraglichen geschwindigkeiten
sind die ja wohl in deutschland der größte witz überhaupt sind nur die wenigsten erhalten
auch das was sie überhaupt gebucht haben ja bis zu bei der telekom ok gib mich zu ja
und trotzdem fühle ich mich irgendwie verarscht und laut dem letzten bericht der bundesnetzagentur
bekommen nur 70 prozent mindestens die hälfte der vereinbarten übertragungsrate 70 prozent
die hälfte das muss man sich mal auf der zunge zergehen lassen lediglich 16,4 prozent
erhalten das gebuchte oder gar mehr das ist doch wohl ein witz wie ich diese worte hasse
bis zu ja das ist ja schon schlimm genug noch dazu werden so natürlich auch viele
statistiken wunderschön gerechnet wenn man halt die vertraglich vereinbarten zahlen
nimmt ja und unter dem twitter erklärt was wirklich ankommt ist das denn so schwer also
im statistiken faken und und sachen schön rechnen sind wir gut guckt euch mal die pünktlichkeit
statistik der bahn an also krasser zusammen faken kann sie nicht mehr auf den weg zu bringen
dass den anbietern sowas verbietet ist es so schwer zu regeln dass die anbieter auch
eine mindestgeschwindigkeit mit angeben müssen sagen wir mal mindestens 400 mit maximal
ein gigabit und alle sind doch zufrieden noch dazu soll natürlich auch die preise angepasst
werden nämlich nur 400 mit erhält die sollte natürlich auch nur für 400 mit zahlen und
nicht für ein gigabit wo ist bitteschön hier der gesetzgeber diese taktik gibt es
schon seit jahrzehnten geändert wird aber rein gar nichts und ja ich rede hier übrigens
nur die ganze zeit vom festen die können ja die können jetzt ja nicht einfach ein
gesetz machen was das ändert ich mein stellt euch mal vor die politische karriere ist zu
ende und man würde sich die option verbauen dass man vielleicht in den aufsichtsrat von
telekom oder von wo davon könnte also das kann man natürlich das geht nicht das ist
ausgeschlossen das stimmt tatsächlich die telekom so schlechter ruft der telekom auch
ist die anderen sind noch schlechter man muss der telekom echt zugute halten wenn
die telekom was verkauft zum größten teil funktioniert der kram das problem was die
telekom hat das problem was die telekom hat ist dass die technik langsam am ende ist das
was die telekom verkauft funktioniert in der regel ganz gut irgendwo netz zu haben mit
telekom lte kommt es hier tatsächlich nur sehr selten vor dass ich mal ein netz habe
also mobil funk also mobil funk muss ich sagen da kann ich ihm nur teilweise recht geben
also eins habe ich festgestellt vielleicht liegt das auch daran damit jetzt an dem neuen
smartphone dass ich mittlerweile ziemlich zuverlässig lte habe auf meiner strecke außer
in meintal in meintal ost da ist regelmäßig alles komplett weg dann noch nicht mal edge
noch nicht mehr edge das dauert dann so zwei drei minuten dann ist er irgendwie beim nächsten
mast oder so aber meintal ost ist immer weg alles ich meine weltstadt meintal ost kann
es ja mal passieren andere geschichte und bei noch einer sache muss ich dir ja ungeliebte
telekom sogar noch mal loben denn auch wenn man internet so langsam war das rauchzeichen
auf mal konne eine deutlich bessere übertragung boten ausfälle gab es wirklich nie das internet
war die ganzen jahre beziehungsweise ich meine die anschlüsse im zu zum haus dass die telekom
back end mäßig ziemlich gut ist da gehe ich da habe ich keine ahnung von aber würde
ich auch von ausgehen ja immer bomben stabil aber natürlich auch teurer als andere das
muss man natürlich dazu sagen ansonsten bin ich von den telekom aber absolut enttäuscht
und ich warte ehrlich gesagt nur noch darauf dass die jetzt auch bei uns im ort hier ankommt
und dann auch noch eine zweite glasfaser leitung verbuddeln wundern wird es mich definitiv
nicht was kann man überhaupt kein problem ich fände super wenn die telekom in zweiter
glasfaser leitung bei mir verlegt das wäre dann bei mir zwar die erste weil er liegt
noch keine aber das können die ruhig machen kriege ich vielleicht auch mal dann dann
gehe ich wieder zur telekom und das ist der grund das ist der grund warum ich meine festnetz
telefonnummer zu einem wolf anbieter portiert habe damit ich easy as fuck mein internet
anbieter wechseln kann das ist halt die sache der regierung und der entsprechenden anbieter
es muss mehr und vor allem bürokratisch es muss unbedingt mehr und vor allem unbürokratisch
geld des bundes locker gemacht werden und zwar nicht eins oder fünf milliarden sondern
deutlich mehr ja natürlich ich weiß nicht ob ich weiß nicht ob es daran liegt dass
wirklich geld fehlt oder dass die koordination beziehungsweise der der wille zum ausbau nicht
da ist diese ist das jetzt nicht einfach aber die gab es vor kurzem ja noch nicht und die
ist natürlich auch irgendwann mal wieder vorbei wie gesagt unbürokratisch bitte geld
wird ja aktuell schon zur verfügung gestellt nur wenn es niemand abruft dann bringt das
natürlich auch niemand was die anbieter müssen in zukunft weiter noch gewisse standards
erfüllen da sie das natürlich nicht freiwillig machen müssen auch hier natürlich gesetze
her es darf nicht mehr auf kupfer gesetzt werden das reicht mit vdsl aktuell zwar noch
aus ist aber natürlich nicht zukunftsfähig und eine sackkasse mit enormen kosten denn
sobald kupfer nicht mehr ausreicht muss die glasfaser dann doch bis ins haus gelegt werden
läuft das viel jetzt eigentlich ordentlich kann ich die bittrate wieder ein bisschen
hoch stellen die kann dann natürlich entsorgt werden es muss auf glasfaser gesetzt werden
da gibt es überhaupt keine alternative nicht nur für privatleute sondern hauptsächlich
für die wirtschaft und damit natürlich auch uns youtuber und glaubt mir youtube mit meiner
alten telekom leitung das war gar nicht lustig und so gut du hast ein gigabit über kupfer
das geht oder besser gesagt ist die kupfer leitung 2 meter 50 lang oder ich wusste bisher
gar nicht dass es kupfer anschlüsse mit gigabit noch gibt ja das ist ok das ist das ist das
würde ich nicht als kupfer ist für mich das alte zweitrad kupfer leitungsding von der
telekom dass die koachs kabel von vom fernseh vom kabelnetz dass da letztendlich auch kupfer
oder irgendein metall drinne ist ja aber das das ist das ist das zählt bei mir nicht als
kupferleitung auch eingehalten werden wenn ich ein gigabit bestelle dann muss sich das
auch erhalten ansonsten muss er anbieter bis 100 meter gibt das ne da sind nur zwei leitungen
über zwei leitungen machen das nicht so ohne weiteres über zwei adern ungeschirmte ungeschirmte
adern irgendwo im haus die da rumfliegen ich glaube nicht dass man ein gigabit verlässlich
über mehr als ein paar meter über über zwei kupfer adern kriegt
anders geht es nicht ja und zum abschluss noch ein bisschen was positives dass ich los
werden möchte denn ja das internet in deutschland das ist scheiße da brauchen wir überhaupt
nicht darüber reden keine diskussion aber wer kritisiert muss natürlich auch einige
positive dinge nennen und muss man das internet ist scheiße reicht der mir zumindest einfällt
denn so langsam das netz in deutschland ist es scheint aber ziemlich stabil zu sein und
ja hat man heute gesehen hat man heute gesehen also der einzige positive punkt bei mir was
internetausbau in deutschland angeht ist wir sind noch nicht die allerletzten aber wir
sind auf dem weg dahin gut andere länder die stören ja aktuell über die hohe datenlast
führe man sich in deutschland fragt wo ist überhaupt das problem denn probleme gibt
es hier wirklich keine großen was vielleicht natürlich auch irgendwie mit der schwachen
internetanbindung zu tun haben könnte trotzdem in der hinsicht ein lob an unser internet
aber nur ein ganz ganz ganz kleines denn der ist der ist einfach scheiße ja ich gebe
also ich würde sich bei allem zustimmen aber bei einem grund grundtenor würde ich würde
ich mich anschließen habe ich ja auch schon mich in paar videos darüber darüber ausgelassen
so jetzt gucken wir mal ob ich die bandbreite wieder hoch stellen kann ob das ganze dann
auch funktioniert
fack lieg leute lieg stream settings lieg lieg überall überall liegs so stellen wir
mal wieder hoch auf 4 9 okay stats ist set
das scheint gerade zu funktionieren den stream key kann man gar nicht mal einblenden im stream
das haben sie gut gemacht
gears tactics juckt mich eigentlich nicht wirklich
was für den frazier also wo man auch mal zur ursprünglichen frage ganz am anfang vom
stream kommen hat irgendjemand einen guten kalender was technik events für das jeweilige
jahr angeht weil ich würde mir gerne mal wieder ein paar präsentationen keynote sonstiges
gedöns angucken erst um danach ein bisschen abzulästern was gezeigt wird und außerdem
weil ich es immer ganz interessant finde dass wir mit dem chat zusammen anzugucken hat er
in den guten kalender wo man so die ganzen events die so keine anwandert apple wieder
was neues 100 microsoft in eine konferenz man ist gut games kommen geschiss fällt ja
aus aber sowas hat hat da irgendjemand eine gute seite wo man die ganzen events sieht
am besten halt auch mit eu zeiten somit mit also jetzt nicht die nur n a zeiten haben
mnet in münchen baut g fast also klingeldraht vom keller bis wohnung ok keller bis wohnung
mag noch funktionieren je nachdem wie hoch das haus ist
computerwelt at events computerwelt at jetzt kommen die österreichische jahre schweizer
hatten wir schon am start jetzt kommt die österreichische am start jetzt immer hier
richtig international zumindest deutschsprachig
was ist das c++ move semantik das sind eher irgendwelche offline events die man buchen
kann oder weniger weniger events wo live streams gehalten werden das ist eher so ein konferenz
teilnehmer dings kalender wo man wo man sich anmelden kann
ja das war ja war schon ganz schön war schon ganz schön bassmord bassmord heavy
10 minutes know how was macht das für einen satz 10 minuten know how break
ach das ist eine das ist eine pause in der man was lernt oder was soll man das computer
das muss ich mir mal aufschreiben ich brauche ich brauche einen ordentlichen kalender
IT IT event kalender gibt es da vielleicht muss man kurz danach so IT event kalender
2020 schon mal was mit AWS lambda gemacht nee tatsächlich noch gar nicht mit AWS also
AWS habe ich noch noch ich überlege ob ich AWS überhaupt ich glaube AWS habe ich noch
nie verwendet das einzige was ich bisher verwendet habe ist google google dings wo ich mir immer
den namen nicht merken kann die google cloud plattform diese da haben und azure azure
sag mir mal einer eine 10 stellige prim zahl what the fuck wobei man das wahrscheinlich
relativ relativ einfach googeln kann oder kann man nicht googeln was
google können
das kam ja sogar noch relativ einfach selbst ausrechnen also nicht im kopf außer man ist
wahnsinnig big brain sondern in dem programm 10 stellig ist ja nur wirklich nicht so viel
äh was wie viel wie viel stellen doch 10 stellen ist doch nicht viel 10 stellen ja so
was hier bräuchte man genau ja so ein kalender meine ich doch so was so was brauchen wir
wo ist denn immer die bixby developer sessions siehst du dank dem stream am sonntag weiß
ich jetzt auch was bixby ist bixby war der samsung voice assistant oder sowas was samsung
ja samsung serie ja mal gucken was ich für questions hier wieder übersehen habe kannst
du mal kurz wissen was nein also was kommt als nächstes kann ich an hallo welt in kobold
ne stimmt das wäre ich das erinnert mich an was wir wollten uns mal kobold im stream angucken
wie alle solche sind leicht zufrieden zu stellen aber dafür sind wir ganz schön viel am meckern
immer habt ihr eigentlich eure maske heute aufgehabt leute habt heute alle eure maske
aufgehabt ich nicht weil ich bin ich aus dem haus gegangen war nicht draußen ok leute
ich sehe ich sehe wir verstehen uns wir verstehen uns ihr seid noch in amsterdam am flug was
ist aber hier ist hier ist hier on tour die masken sind in amsterdam ich kann sicher nicht
warum nicht hätte aber sein können keine ahnung vielleicht vielleicht fährst du mit
dem physik physik grill mal nach amsterdam hallo sir of jelly was wieso ist eigentlich
kali nukes das go to os vor heckermans weil er viel dabei ist man das hat man doch alles
schon erst mal ganz questions löschen was du für ein smartphone bevorzugst ja das war
wollte ich vorhin noch kurz was zu sagen also wie gesagt ich habe jede menge android tablets
ich habe ipads und ich habe halt nur iphones tatsächlich als smartphones bisher gehabt und
ich habe mir halt noch nie eins gekauft wenn ich mir eins kaufen würde würde ich mir vielleicht
auch ein android kaufen aber aktuell ist es so dass die letzten drei smartphones inklusive
dem aktuellen von der firma bekommen habe wo ich arbeite und die dinger taugen dementsprechend
habe ich da kein anreiz irgendwie was neues zu kaufen ach das physik grill ist schon vergeben
oh sebaro das habe ich nicht mitgekriegt pippenhans was sagst du zum fairphone lange nichts mehr
gehört von ich finde es ist an sich ein gutes projekt ich habe plus das gefühl ich glaube
weil ich habe keine ahnung ob das wirklich so ist dass es klau dass das keine kein großartiger
erfolg wird weil die leute halt lieber die hälfte für ausgeben mit gleichwertigen features
aber schon ewig her ich wusste gar nicht ob es das fairphone überhaupt schon gibt
mittlerweile ich habe da mal vor fünf jahren oder so ein ct was drüber gelesen ich bin
ja so alt wie ich ja immer noch ein ct aber ich habe ct seit 20 jahren oder so ein ct
aber ich habe hier den stapel ct ist der ist ohne mist von der erde bis zur decke in der
in der ecke vom zimmer und ich gucke da nie rein boomer richtig pur
meine eltern haben sich einen neuen fernseher gekauft an dem alten fernseher war ein raspberry
pie dran meine eltern wundern sich warum sie kein internetseiten aufmachen können auf
dem pie war ein pie hall den zusammenhang verstehe ich nicht
und das ist eine frage die kommt oft ich ihr wisst ja ich bin nicht der große pro was desktop
pc komponenten angeht ich kenne mich damit immer nur aus wenn wenn ich mir selbst was
kaufen will dass die haben den strom vom pie weggemacht her dann
ich wollte mir dieses jahr einen pc zusammen stellen und wollte dich nun fragen ob du an
meiner stelle noch mit den komponenten warten würdest wie grafikaner und so weiter auf die
neue generation ja wenn es nicht eilt würde ich warten tatsächlich aber wenn du sagst
ich will jetzt unbedingt neuen pc weil ich irgendwas nicht spielen kann oder mir auf
den sack geht dass man alles so langsam ist dann würde ich jetzt gleich kaufen warten
lohnt in der regel nicht wenn man wenn man jetzt akut bedarf an neuer hardware hat ansonsten
wenn es nicht so akut ist dann kannst du warten ich habe ja auch gewartet ich war letztes
jahr kurz davor mir einen ryzen pc zusammenzustellen der absolut sinnlos gewesen wäre weil ich
rechner hab der immer noch schneller ist als 95 prozent an anderen rechner aber ich war
kurz ich war kurz davor aber ich habe es dann trotzdem sein gelassen
hat das damals für ascii porn gereicht ich glaube sowas gab es damals nicht
was die schweiz wie viele andere sind fake gut was man in der krise gut gesehen hat also
ich weiß nicht was an der schweiz fake gut ist wenn die sagen es gibt ein gigabit internet
und es funktioniert das ist ja kein fake das geht es geht dann halt
hoffentlich merken die politiker dass das internet stark genutzt wird die krone also
wenn die das wenn die erst korona dafür brauchen um zu merken dass das internet gebraucht wird
dann würde das tatsächlich unseren ausbau erklären ja
jeder der will kann eine direktanbindung haben und das ist nicht teuer für 5 naja also
weiß ich ob das nicht nicht nicht teuer ist also ja wenn du jetzt in firma bist die übelst
viel die fettkohle hat mit sicherheit aber ich weiß was wir für unsere 2 gigabit anbindung
ja das stimmt nicht so ganz was wir für unsere 2 gigabit dark fiber leitung wobei
sie sogar mehr mittlerweile als 2 gigabit bezahlen und das ist doch schon ordentlich
was kostet es denn mal angenommen ich habe wirklich eine firma die wo nicht einfach quasi
in der nähe schon irgendwo was liegt wo man was abzweigen kann sondern wo wirklich was
hingelegt werden muss glaubt nicht dass das so so man nebenbei easy easy money ist kennst
du eine gute möglichkeit sound von zwei geräten oder vm und host zu mixen um zwei sourcen
gleichzeitig zu hören ja zum beispiel bei einer form mit virtualisiertem sound habe
ich immer noch crackling weil also das beste was du machen kannst für ordentlichen sound
in der vm ist eine usb soundkarte da reicht auch eine ganz billige das ist besser als
diese ganze vmw emulierte soundkarten gedöns nimm nimm eine usb soundkarte eine billige
usb soundkarte von amazon irgendwas case muss ja nicht vielleicht irgendwas ist auf jeden
fall besser als das vmw emulierte zeug und mach hier usb usb weiterleitung in die vm
und dann holst du dir das würde ich wirklich jedem empfehlen mehr als eine eine audio audio
source hast da holst du dir einen ganz kleinen mixer für für kleines geld und mich das
zusammen da kannst du dann auch schön dein dein kopfhörer dran machen dass den sound
dann auch getrennt von je nachdem wenn du mehrere rechner hast von konsole vom arbeitsrechner
vom spiele rechner vielleicht noch auf ts anders
gute gute reisen mainboards kein schimmer was sagt er hier
es naja man muss ja mal sagen also je nachdem was es für eine firma ist ist das ist das
nicht viel je nachdem was man was das für eine firma ist ist das nicht viel aber natürlich
insgesamt betracht ist schon ordentlich teuer was mord drohungen trennten warum trennt es
mord mord drohungen mögen die leute barbara schöneberger beim computerspiele preis nicht
mord drohungen gegen virologen die leute haben echt einen kompletten dachschaden
was für ein günstiger mixer also der klein der kleine jamaha mixer ist ziemlich gut war
das der jetzt wenn es den noch eins kleiner gibt dann kann man auch den eins kleiner nehmen
ja der da ist ganz gut ich weiß nicht ob das noch der aktuellste ist da müssen wir
mal gucken kann auch gleich stehen nehmen da ein bisschen mehr eingänge der ist der ist
ganz gut wie viele spur oder musst du mal auf die seite gucken bei denen ich würde
sagen drei drei oder vier zwei drei ich würde vermuten drei sieht etwas auf a kill aus warum
ist es super das teil du verwendest ja nicht alles was die das sind die der vorteil bei
diesen kleinen ist auch auch von bei den kleinen mixer von bäringer ich weiß dass bäringer
nicht die nicht den besten rufe hat in den audiokreisen aber für so ein bisschen wir
mixen ein paar sachen daheim zusammen ums kopfhörer zu hören ist das jetzt nicht so nicht so
wild die kleinen dinger haben den vorteil die haben die haben noch anschlüsse für
einen 3,5 millimeter headset mikrofon das haben die größeren besseren mixer alle nicht
das heißt dafür sind die dinger ganz gut ansonsten braucht die einen adapter und da
gibt es gar nicht so viele ja ja die ich ich habe auch hier ich habe auch den den allen
kleinsten bäringer mixer heute würde ich mir aber den da kaufen oder vielleicht sogar
den also ich würde den vorziehen da ein bisschen mehr funktionen als das bäringer ding ich
hatte mir mal den hier also ich habe jetzt ich habe ja zwei sachen ich habe einmal mein
moto sound usb audio interface mit dem ich nahezu alles mache das hat 16 spuren und für
headset für das headset mikro und die xbox habe ich noch so einen kleinen 300 irgendwie
so ein klein ganz kleines furz mixer ding für 50 euro scheint mir die zweite auflage
zu sein das sieht ein bisschen anders aus als meiner wobei ne das ist ja aber wenn ich
die auswahl hätte heute würde ich mir würde ich mir den kaufen ich benutze den tribo oder
ich benutze den in meinem audio interface ich habe den rechner per tost link kabel am
audio interface dran und ab das ab die kopfhörer auch am audio interface dran und da ist ja
natürlich ein digital konverter und auch einfach stärker drin das hört sich eigentlich ganz
gut an ja voice meter habe ich auch mal benutzt aber voice meter hat verzögerungen weil
wahrscheinlich software und weil wahrscheinlich windows machen eigentlich gerade so die zahlen
die weltweiten korona zahlen excellent das kokona land hat es geschafft haben sie jetzt
mehr als die restliche welt zusammen nicht ganz oder hell yeah es tut mir da schon für
die leute ein bisschen leid gerade gerade die den zahl so schon nicht gut geht die kriegen
es halt richtig ab aber freiheit genau
es ja auf twitter rumkacken es lohnt sich nicht netcolon hat einen super ruf das stimmt
tatsächlich daher da habe ich wenig schlechtes drüber gehört aber die sind ja auch nicht
ganz deutschlandweit aktiv oder netcolon wir auch einen ganz guten ruf früher hat
verhandeln nett das ist das was dann zu alles wurde und ich weiß nicht wer alles gekauft
hat wer hat alles wer hat alles gekauft guck mal webmail gibt es noch alles des auto auto
united internet wahrscheinlich mein ls dsl aber webmail 7.0 login gibt es noch ja ich
habe mein passwort vergessen ganz nett genau wo sind wir da wie sieht eigentlich so der
trend bei uns aus seitdem was aufgemacht haben man sieht es ja nicht so richtig weil
es ja zwei drei wochen verzögert kommt aber zumindest die usa geht gut ab das wieder viele
falsche infos okay das hatten wir vorhin schon
was echt hast du so eine schwierige hausnummer dass ich sie finden ja das hatten wir gerade
wie gesagt usb soundcard nein kenne ich nicht hatten wir gerade haben wir doch bei uns auch
haben wir doch bei uns auch da gab es doch letztens den typ der erzählt hat ja ich weiß
auch nicht was die regierung davon hat jetzt die wirtschaft dass die wirtschaft den bach
runtergeht aber das muss was mit neuer weltordnung zu tun haben excellent big brain wenn da nix
mehr einfällt dann muss das was mit neuer weltordnung zu tun haben natürlich 5g maß
warum die sich alle so auf 5g verstand da teilweise einschießen leuchtet mir überhaupt
nicht ein ich meine das einzige was die leute ja nicht checken ist es gibt länder so wie
china zum beispiel haben halt kein bock schlusslich zu sein wie wir was internetausbau und mobilfunk
ausbau angeht da die haben auch schon 5g das ist ja unvorstellbar das hier ist perfekt
was ein smoothie maker excellent so einen smoothie maker da könnte ich könnte man ich könnte
wirklich wieder den smoothie maker gebrauchen weil meine ist kaputt kopiere mich eins ok
weil du es bist ruby ja achtung das hier ist die eins aus dem twitter das ist nicht irgendeine
eins das ist die eins poggers was ist das corona proteste
dass er sieht das sieht wirklich aus das sieht wirklich aus das sieht original kokona aus
der türk aller mehr kokona kannst du nicht aussehen guckt euch mal an der typ da mit
der kamera am start klein ok was was er verschmerzen kommt mal wie durchgeweicht wie durchgeweicht
die maske ist
ja ja ja ja ja ja ja
Dependent wort wie was was gibt's
Ist das ist das wirklich ist das wirklich alles vom gleichen protest manches sieht so reingeschnitten aus
aus manche sieht so reingeschnitten aus irgendwie
Der arme bill gates was kann der dafür
Bill Gates hat ja wirklich mal vor ein paar Jahren
ne
ne tettock gehalten zum thema epidemie und und virus und sowas
wahrscheinlich kommen sie daher dass sie das der das bill gates
das bill gates warum ausgerechnet bill gates
die amis
die haben echt da schaden
ja ich glaub's dir
warum sollte denn irgendein land fake death numbers rausgeben
mit jedem mit jedem toter steigt bedeutet das doch nur das was nicht richtig gelaufen ist
China gibt tatsächlich fake numbers raus aber nicht wirklich fake death numbers sondern fake numbers
jetzt geht das los
da haben sie ja gerade den richtigen am start
jetzt fehlt eigentlich nur noch das wo ist der 5g mast
ich weiß ich weiß wir haben in deutschland haben wir auch mittlerweile sowas
ich hab's ich hab letztens auch ein paar sachen aus deutschland gesehen
oh oh oh new world order da haben wir's wieder
kennst du den tube nicht? ne, kenn ich
was ist das?
oh das ist ja verdammt das geht ja überhaupt nicht dass es
große wellen gibt und man jetzt nicht surfen kann also wirklich jetzt
ich verstehe die manchmal überhaupt nicht also ich mein das mag am dialect liegen aber ich verstehe auch
auf den demos wenn deutsche interviewt werden teilweise die leute nicht
das ist so eine mischung aus wirren gerede und irgendwie genuschel oftmals
da versteht sie überhaupt nichts mehr
warum befragen die immer nur solche experten ich vermute da zwei gründe
erstens weil es dort ziemlich viele solche experten gibt und zweitens
das darf man bei solchen berichten nie aus acht lassen weil es sich gut macht
für das video und man kann natürlich mit der passenden
auswahl der interview partner beziehungsweise der leute die man zeigt
und interviewt auch berichte in gewisse wirkung ist eine gewisse die wirkung
lenken wie so ein bericht hat aber ich vermute mal dass dort auch der anteil
solcher spezialisten ziemlich hoch ist
wie er fragt was ist denn jetzt los was geht was haben die denn da
oder sowas die wahl von die wahn von jerry show wird da ist klar
natürlich
jawoll
jawoll die leute wie lange geht das noch eine minuten keine minuten halte ich das
gedacht warum
jawoll